>>> WELCOME BACK EVERYONE.
ELECON OFFICIALS IN GILLESPE,
TEXAS, LEAVING THEIR POST IN THE
LEAD-UP TO TOMORROW'S ELECTION.
WHO IS LEFT IN CHARGE?
ELECTION PRECINCT JUDGE WHO
DOESN'T ACCEPT THE RESULTS OF
THE 2020 PRESIDENTIAL CONTEST.
CNN'S ED LAVANDERA REPORTS NOW.
>> THIS IS THE AUCTION BARN MOST
OF THE TIME.
>> Reporter: ON ELECTION DAY,
DAVID TRANSCRIBES WILL BE HERE
SERVING THE VOTERS OF PRECINCT
13 IN GILLESPIE COUNTY, TEXAS.
>> YOU HAVE AN OFFICIAL TITLE
IN.
>> YES, ELECTION JUDGE.
>> Reporter: ELECTION PRECINCT
JUDGE USUALLY WOULDN'T RAISE ANY
EYEBROWS.
>> YOU BELIEVE THE 2020 ELECTION
WAS STOLEN FROM DONALD TRUMP?
>> YES, I DO.
>> WHY SHOULD SOMEONE LIKE YOU
SERVE IN THIS KIND OF OFFICIAL
CAPACITY FOR AN ELECTION?
>> I WOULD THINK I WOULD
PROBABLY BE A GOOD CANDIDATE
BECAUSE I'M GOING TO BE REALLY
KEEN LOOKING FOR ANYTHING THAT
LOOKS WRONG.
MY OBJECTIVE IS INTEGRITY, NOT
THAT MY GUYS WIN, BUT INTEGRITY.
>> Reporter: THE STORY OF HOW
GILLESPIE COUNTY REACHED THIS
POINT IS A CAUTIONARY TALE OF
HOW THE 2020 ELECTION DENYING
CONSPIRACY THEORIES VIRUS KEEPS
SPREADING.
THERE'S NOTHING GLAMOROUS ABOUT
THE GILLESPIE COUNTY ELECTION
ADMINISTRATORS OFFICE.
INSIDE, THE SMALL ELECTION TEAM
DID THEIR WORK.
BY MID AUGUST, ALL THREE
EMPLOYEES HAD QUIT, THREE MONTHS
BEFORE THE MIDTERM ELECTION.
>> THE ELECTION TROUBLE HERE
DATES BACK TO 2019 WHEN A BALLOT
MEASURE ASKED VOTERS WHETHER OR
NOT FLUORIDE SHOULD BE USED IN
THE CITY'S DRINKING WATER.
THE ANTI-FLUORIDE ACTIVIST WHO
LOST, QUESTIONED THE INTEGRITY
OF THAT ELECTION, AND THEN THE
2020 PRESIDENTIAL ELECTION CAME
ALONG POURING GASOLINE ON THE
FLAMES OF ELECTION CONSPIRACY
THEORIES.
EVEN THOUGH DONALD TRUMP WON
THIS COUNTY WITH 79% OF THE
VOTE, SOME REPUBLICANS WERE
CONVINCED SOMETHING WASN'T
RIGHT.
IN AUGUST OF THIS YEAR, THE
ELECTIONS ADMINISTRATOR, ANISSA
HERRERA WAS DONE.
SHE WROTE THAT THREATS AGAINST
ELECTION OFFICIALS, DANGEROUS
MISINFORMATION, POOR WORKING
CONDITIONS AND ABSURD
LEGISLATION HAVE COMPLETELY
CHANGED HER JOB.
>> I'VE HAD TO LEARN A LOT OF
INFORMATION REALLY QUICKLY.
>> Reporter: WITH NO ELECTION
TEAM IN PLACE, IT FELL TO THE
COUNTY CLERK, LINDSEY BROWN TO
SERVE.
>> PEOPLE THAT HAVE BEEN IN
ELECTIONS BEFORE, PEOPLE WHO
HAVE WORKED IT BEFORE HAVE
TAPPED INTO THEIR KNOWLEDGE AND
WISDOM.
>> I UNDERSTAND THE TEXAS
SECRETARY OF STATE'S OFFICE HAS
SENT IN ELECTION TRAINERS,
SENDING IN INSPECTORS.
HOW VALUABLE OR HOW NEEDED HAVE
THOSE PEOPLE BEEN?
>> VERY VALUABLE.
>> JERRY IS A GEL LISS SPI
COUNTY DEMOCRAT WHO WILL WORK AS
AN ALTERNATE PRECINCT JUDGE.
HE ATTENDED THE POLLING TRAINING
SESSION AND SAID WHAT HE HEARD
FROM THE ELECTION CONSPIRACY
THEORISTS TROUBLES HIM.
>> WHAT ARE WE SUPPOSED TO DO
WITH THE FAKE IDs THAT THE BIDEN
ADMINISTRATION IS ISSUING TO
ILLEGALS WHEN THEY TRAVEL ACROSS
THE BORDER.
THE SECRETARY OF STATE SAID --
REPRESENTATIVE SAID THAT'S NOT
HAPPENING, AND WE WENT ON.
>> Reporter: FOR NOW OFFICIALS
ARE HOPING FOR THE BEST.
>> DO YOU FEEL CONFIDENT THIS
ELECTION WILL GO OFF SMOOTHLY?
>> YES, SIR.
>> Reporter: DON, THAT ELECTION
PRECINCT JUDGE YOU HEARD FROM,
HE BELIEVES IN 2020 THERE WERE
2,000 DONALD TRUMP VOTES FLIPPED
FROM TRUMP TO BIDEN THERE IN
GILLESPIE COUNTY.
THIS IS A LIE PEDALLED BY MY
PILLOW CEO MIKE LINDELL.
FOR THE FIRST TIME IN MEMORY,
THEY'RE SENDING OUT ELECTION
POLL WALKERS ON ELECTION DAY
TOMORROW.
>> ED LAVANDERA, THANK YOU.